hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the match magnus cross and versus
prager ananda if you've seen in game one
it was a pretty pretty tied the game but
uh in the end magnus was able to outplay
prague in the queen's end game being a
pawn up but it took him quite a few
moves but in the end he was able to win
then in game two uh prague was doing
okay and at some point magnus was able
to win the game with the black pieces
which means that now magnus is leading
two to zero and uh prague needs to
well win at least this game to force
game four and win that one at the first
tie breaks if he uh doesn't if magnus
gets a draw in this one or a win then
the match is over so it's quite an
enjoyable game uh let's see what
happened here magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with knight to f3 he
goes for that at the opening uh we have
d5 by probably with e3 knight to f6 c
for now uh and e6 we have knight to c3
and c5 uh inviting white to go for
basically d4 which transposes into the
target defense the three knights of the
tarash uh and magnus uh accepts this so
d4 we are in the uh three knights of the
tarash knights to c6 and now c captures
on d5 he captures and bishop to b5 so
this is all very standard stuff uh c
captures on the e4 knight captures now
threatening to win some material here
assault private defense would bishop to
d7 we have castles and now bishop to d6
magnus goes back knight to f3 now
putting pressure on the d5 pawn and you
no longer have to worry about the c6
square so bishop to e6 now we shift
attention to the d5 pawn uh b3 magnus
preparing to think of the dark square
bishop to this long diagonal prague
castles and the bishop the g2 and now
the position has been reached before uh
a6 is another move uh rooked c8 is a
normal queen a7 is a known move but
there are like maybe 10 games altogether
that have redisposition but the move
prague plays is a new one he plays
bishop to g4 and it is not as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
it's an annoying pin uh you can't really
move the knight you can't move the queen
otherwise we're going to mess up
your uh pawn structure in front of the
king so magnus first tries with h3 he
wants to check if the prague will go
back or he will go to h5 he goes to h5
and now magnus just brings the bishop
back so now the knight on f3 can move we
have rook to c8 prague continues
development and now knight the h4 magnus
offers a trade of light square bishops
and he wants to win the f5 square uh all
all to his knight so bishop to g6 i'm
not allowing this beautiful f5 square to
be captured by the knight and magnus now
grabs the bishop pair so knight captures
and g6 h captures and knight to b5
putting pressure on the bishop here
bishop to b8 and now bishop to f3 now
it's uh
also bishop to g4 can be played you
attacked the rook here it's a very
annoying move uh maybe prague trades and
that captures bishop captures but um
uh magnus would have to give up the
bishop pair so and also he's leading the
match by uh
a margin of two points so bishop to f3
is a very nice solid move uh he
basically says okay if you want anything
you're the one who's going to have to
force it so we have a6 uh knight to d4
and now rook to e8 magnus continues
training knight captures on c6 b
captures this improves um
sort of the stability of the d5 pawn but
the c6 spawn will remain weak so here
queen d3 developing the queen magnus
connects the rooks and now also as the
a6 pawn is attacked
a5 now we have rook ate the c1 now we're
going to put pressure on this c6 spawn
uh and here we have knight to e4 you
can't really play c5 even though it
looks like a good idea because we're
just going to remove the defender of the
d5 pawn and then pick it up so that
would be a terrible uh mistake so after
knight to e4 and this is a great square
for the knight magnus just uh trades now
bishop for knight so at night the bishop
captures an e4 rook captures an e4 and
now rook the c2 magnus says all right
i'm just going to double up
on the on the c file and go after your
c6 pawn later on i can play queen to a6
and put even more pressure on the pawn
uh and here i've probably wanted to keep
it
clean if he wanted to play a nice safe
game or if he wasn't losing the match by
a two-point margin he would probably
play queen to d6 adds a defender to the
c6 pawn also you are threatening
checkmate and after something like g3
even a4 looks like a very very uh sneaky
idea trying to create a sort of a
weakness on the queen side but after
rook to c2 uh prague played rook to h4
so the idea is that prague wants to play
queen to d6 uh threat and checkmate and
if magnus plays g3 he wants to capture
the pawn on h3 and now magnus says all
right rook after c1 he puts more
pressure on the pawn uh and now prague
plays a queen to d6 the pawn is nicely
defended and he's threatening to bring
the queen over to the h2 pawn uh to the
h2 square and magnus uh well he uh kind
of uh if you've watched the live stream
he was kind of laughing at the position
or maybe he was just enjoying himself
and he played king to f1 he does not
mind the queen coming to h2 and it seems
like a reasonable idea but the funny
thing about this position is that the
move rook h4 which uh prague played to
prevent g3 doesn't prevent g3 whatsoever
but this is one of the uh toughest moves
to spot in in this game
so here g3 is actually the strongest
move i'm just gonna show it to you
because it's uh well after rook captures
an h3 the idea is queen to d4 now let's
uh see what happens we're threatening
checkmate and now the only way to stop
this and not lose terribly is rook to h7
if you play anything else uh then magnus
has queen to g4 and both of your rooks
will be attacked so that's why the rook
on h3 isn't so
nicely placed you're gonna have to play
rook to h7 and now uh queen to a4 we're
gonna go after the c6 pawn and that's it
the g3 pawn completely blocks uh black's
attack and there is no danger here for
white so that's the uh kind of the way
you have to go g3 is by far the
strongest but okay magnus played queen
aking to f1 and now uh prague plays rook
to h5 uh here you could go for queen to
h2 but it doesn't really
yield anything in particular so rook to
h5 was played now the fifth rank will be
nicely defended but uh
that that will not be enough magnus
plays queen to a6 puts more pressure on
the c6 pawn also the rook on c8 is now
hanging
rook to f8 and now rook captures on c6
now prague will shift everything to the
attack or a queen to h2 now comes rook
to c8 when you're stronger of course you
trade uh bishop to d6 guarding the rook
here uh rook captures bishop captures
and magnus instantly plays rook to c8 so
it's a very very uh tricky position uh
but uh whatever prague plays uh will
still losing the game so he plays rook
to f5 it seems like you are able to put
some pressure on the position after
queen g3 maybe you can even threaten
checkmate maybe force magnus to go back
with his pieces uh the problem is uh
here white has uh or rather magnus has a
forced checkmate in 15 moves
and it's uh well it's just a beautiful
one so feel free to pause the video and
try to spot this mate in 15
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
rook captures an f8 it is exactly what
magnus played
and now just to show you what happens uh
okay
in the game the rook was captured which
is the best defense but even if you
don't accept the rook uh you're still
gonna get checkmated queen to c8 with
the threat of rook h8 checkmate you have
to run with the king rook 8 king to g5
and now we're going to play bishop to g7
a very important move enforcing this
checkmate and after let's see queen g3
now prague can threaten checkmate now we
just go for bishop h6 check king to f6
queen to d8 check we're gonna play king
e5 and rook to eight uh rook to e8 or
queen to e7 will be checkmate as the
pawn uh covers the d4 square so that's
what happens if you don't accept the
rook if you hide the h7 so probably
grabs the rook
but now comes queen to c8 check king the
e7 and bishop to a3 and now of course
you see that there really are no good
squares for the black king uh in the
game king f6 was played and this just
runs into a very nasty checkmate queen
to d8 and it was in this position uh
basically that prague resigned the game
uh because it doesn't matter if you play
king the e5 or king the e6 you're still
getting checkmated with queen to e7 also
the same applies for king to e5 queen to
e7 is still check made you cover this
the pawn covers this uh there is no
square for the king but uh
you know continue in the fashion that we
advertise the video uh what happens if
you give up the queen then we continue
uh and it will be a a forced checkmate
in 15 from that position so queen d6 can
be played hoping to kind of give up your
uh
queen for the bishop but you don't even
get to do that queen c7 check now wins
the queen for nothing king f6 we're
going to play queen captures on d6 check
king g5 queen to d8 with check we're
going to play king to h6 now queen to h8
with check king g5 now bishop to e7
would check f6 and now bishop to d6 and
now once those pawns start marching
forward there is no uh saving that kim
king and there really is no useful move
here for black whatever you play we're
gonna play f4 check and now you're gonna
have to start giving up material the
king has nowhere to go rook captures
we're gonna play e captures with the
check king f5 and now queen to e8 and
now there really is nowhere for you to
go g4 will just be a spectacular
checkmate even if you play g5 it doesn't
matter g for his checkmate because the
queen covers the g6 square so really a
fine uh fine game and really a
spectacular finish by magnus after uh
prague played this rook to f5 idea just
rook captures an f8 a fourth check
making 15 just spectacular uh it's not
necessarily uh accurate that magnus
calculated it all the way to the end of
course he could have just calculated to
the point where he knows that he's going
to win the queen and then something good
will happen uh but it's nice when when
things work out uh so yeah although
prague was unstoppable in the first
three matches and he was on 100 percent
uh in his match against magnus he lost
all three games uh and uh in the
interview after the game uh they asked
uh pragernanda if he thinks that magnus
played his best here and he said that uh
well he he uh he doesn't think that
magnus played his best but he's uh you
know uh he even
when he doesn't bring his best it is
obviously very very strong
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh
tough tough for anyone who was hoping
for a prague win here but uh when you
face magnus this is the most likely
outcome as many have you know uh seen
uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed that
if you have any other games that you
would like me to cover feel free to use
hashtag hashtag suggestion uh i would
like to thank kirsten lehmann's guy
lefleux course dk benjamin uh mark
galassie and fred eckerman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world like this uh
wonderful oslo esport cup that we are
having here uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and another big big
congratulations to everyone who spotted
that forced mate in 15.
see you soon